Hey, hey, hey, hey!
I missed you guys, man!
(EXCITED LAUGHTER)
When I first came in,
I was just thinking
about this day,
or like, the day
when I walk out.
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
INTERVIEWER:
I'm nervous.
This the first show on our tour.
It was delayed a year because--
Well, you know
what happened was...
SPEAKER:
DMX is like a prophet.
If it wasn't for that man,
I'd probably have lost my mind.
He ain't ever shy away
from the truth.
-He human.
-He's like us.
SPEAKER 2: He's been
the same dude his whole life
and that's why it's hard
for him to change
because he is the same dude.
I wasn't eating
three meals a day.
I didn't have clothes
freely given to me.
I came here to give a message,
the Gospel according to X.
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
INTERVIEWER 2:
Do you know what you're getting?
No, I don't.
SPEAKER 3:
You're getting roughly
half the money on signing.
Can you take the microphone off,
please?
If you know we going
to these different cities,
I don't know why it's not
already taken care of.
All these people stealing
and owin'-- I owe 'em, man.
Fake ass judgments
and shit, man.
-FAN: Can I get a photo?
-DMX: "Can I get this?
Can I get your shirt?"
SPEAKER 6:
(SIGHS)
DMX: Do you really love me?
Or do you just wanna
get something from me?
My goal is to be an inspiration
to someone that I don't know.
I'm talking to you
from a person who grew up
right where you grew up at.
I stole a car from right there.
You gotta turn that pain
into words.
You might not know or think
that you're special to God
because you've been through
difficult situations,
but I'm here to tell you,
that's why you're special
to God.
(FANS CHEER)
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪